Palestinian journalist has been arrested
by Israeli official forces for filming
soldiers and allegedly inciting violence
ali ali live stream to videos on
Facebook of Israeli soldiers operating
in Ramallah now filming IDF soldiers is
illegal in Israel filming an officer
with the intent of quote undermining the
spirit of the army is punishable by up
to five years in prison
the IDF says that the man they arrested
was inciting violence against the State
of Israel and the army or Gaza based
reporter Hindu dari has details
a Palestinian journalist has been
arrested for filming IDF soldiers
Israeli forces raided his home just a
day after he lost your videos on his
Facebook page of the IDF drawing up a
plan of a Palestinian home a procedure
typically done before demolishing the
building the man filmed and edited
videos of IDF troops during the course
of their operational activities while
encouraging violence towards them and
incited attacks directed at the State of
Israel and IDF troops you were sleeping
when we heard a knock at the door in the
middle of the night we woke up and
opened the door they told us they're
soldiers
they asked me whose house is it I said
it's Muhammad Ali's then they asked who
lives upstairs I said it's a leader Ali
so they went upstairs and arrested him
he told me mom don't be afraid I hope I
won't stay there for long she's not
guilty I'm sure he's not we went to the
court and they told us they were
prolonging his detention
Aladar Ali is a well-known Palestinian
journalist working as a correspondent
for the Palestine Broadcasting
Corporation the agency is calling for
the immediate release of its reporter
and says Israel is targeting the
Palestine media these measures are
intended to silence the Palestinian
voice and dim the picture so that Israel
can commit its crimes without any noise
Ali is the latest in a number of
journalists arrested in Palestine within
the past two weeks
you